oh that's so brutal yeah and he doesn't have a lot
of time and now after king d7 rook
takes rogue knight takes the shot
group c logic versus tubo never in a million years
hikaru did i expect a grammy-nominated rapper
to compete against a minecraft minecraft streamer
yeah no i can't do it i can't do it it's all
falling apart the whole operation i don't know if
i'm ready for logic the rapper the dubs doves are
on the case and we're finally gonna have the
game between logic and oh here we go the game
has started it looks like e4 yep okay hikaru uh
what do we know about logic man i think we know
that logic a little bit that i know is that he
likes play e4 e5 symmetrical setups um beyond
that i don't know a whole lot i would say his
understanding is pretty good overall i feel like
he's he's got a good good fundamental grasp of the
basics um i think he's a very slight favorite here
the one thing i would say about tubbo though is i
feel like tubbo has had a lot of experience he's
played a lot more chess right so oh wow okay
four wow is it gonna try to do the the the the
hobo sin fish hook with h5 is is a big question
mark here um i like you know i don't even
well you're saying that uh yeah castle's h3h5
uh-huh okay yes yes he's gonna try to maybe try
to go for the fish hook as uh as forest and
called it there's only one way as far as i
see in this position that logic could run into
trouble and that is bishop f2 king e2 knight d4
correct correct bishop okay let's
play out this sequence so bishop there
right he's threatened that horse that's
threatening that was he's probably just gonna
take it with his horse i take with my horse okay
i think that's the play we worked on pins a lot
where was this degree of analysis and patience
when he gave away his queen for a bishop
like that's a good point actually
right he is he he's now he's much
more patient he's working it out logically
whereas before he was very very like just
that nervous energy and and moving too
quickly it's actually a very good point
how good are logic's checkmate patterns what if
he plays bishop e8 hoping for rookie 8 knight f7
oh that would be beautiful although actually 97
is a very good move by logic the other thing i
realize with logic is that he is a very he's going
to use his time and in general that's a good thing
but if he if he does kind of what xpc was doing it
gets a little bit too low on time bad things could
happen that being said he castles very quickly
and now i think he's looking very very good here
yeah once he's castled it's all good
and night h7 is a great move as well by logic
um yeah it looks like it looks like logic is
off to a flying start here and i think this is
this is just just what the doctor ordered um
for logic especially he is one of i think
one of the favorites potentially and so to
get a very smooth kind of good start
i think it's really important however
and threaten the queen get him away
from that oh oh oh oh we're cafe oh oh
oh wait a minute wait a minute okay i need
to think everything through oh he's slipping
for a minute oh no he slips oh my gosh oh no he
can check right he can check me okay can i get
some can i get some komodo hypes in the chat
wait oh no he made a mouse slip oh my gosh oh
but it's he's still in the game after bishop takes
queen he can take the black rook he's still in the
game weirdly yes he is still in the game and he
could actually be winning in the course of a move
unbelievable but the thing is this tub of see
the king move that's the question he does yeah
yeah and uh well yeah you see uh actually logic
plays rook fade he doesn't even take the rook yeah
because he's obviously thinking about that
move anyway and he sees that he's going to
oh man this is oh that's so unfortunate for logic
oh man look down i wonder if he was on click
click or if he was on oh man dragging but
oh that's so brutal yeah and he doesn't have
a lot of time and now after king d7 rook takes
rogue nightmares what is this doing oh my
god you just what does tubo do here exactly
i don't know i actually don't see i
mean i see a way to give up the rook
and and still be fine but it's never gonna
happen yeah but now b7 b7 oh my gosh this
oh it's game on again oh this is absolutely
unbelievable according to the computer black is
still winning if and only if black takes the rook
and brings back the knight but then black has to
coordinate a rook bishop knight man with a minute
and 20. like wow okay you move the king oh my gosh
this this hikaru the cc can you take the rook oh
because kingdom rugby won yes exactly so king b2
hide behind your pawn logic
oh he went the wrong way i oh ro g2 oh
just don't go king e3 king e3 was mate
but will tubble make a this might be
a draw i could see this being a draw
yeah because logic obviously is is on the
but also tableau is no time oh no oh yeah yo
now you make a queen and now logic is gonna
win the game oh my gosh that's unbelievable
oh wow oh what a turnaround all
the ambulance call the ambulance
okay so let's see what logic is going to do he
still has time this is probably it's going to
do it the other way where he now pushes
the pawn i think exactly push the pawn
exactly you don't even think i just think logic
does he's just he feels he's feeling nerves and
he doesn't want to go into the end game to
begin with i think he's feeling the nerves
and he's too worried that he's gonna make a
stallmate with the king and queen oh but now
queen d6 and king c4 yeah exactly i mean he might
push two well the queen d6 yeah very nice move
that's clean very clean it's a good game by logic
man uh to create that counter play on the queen
side that was not that was not a 1076 flame that
was a high level play is there any stalemates here
with two queens there is xcc has done it a few
times um we're basically like queen d7 king h6
queen of seven i think the temples are wrong oh
whoa that is really strange now there is none
yeah just queen any queen okay that's good too
clean yep what that was a good game honestly
that was a good game by logic like literally
he was only losing because he slipped that's
it right yeah objectively you're right it's a
very clean game definitely a deserved win for him
although the game did get very very
wild bouncy up and down after that
is that what's going on here wow what a game
what a game uh i think that we should focus on
our second matchup of the day okay so anyway we've
got a very standard opening here so it's actually
turned into a very sort of like classical game
very classic approach very slow slow slow play
for both sides which is why it's called the
uh this is called the the juco pianissimo
um of course meaning the very slow version
of it as opposed to the juco piano or
juco piano which is just straightforward oh
that's bold well logic's got to go back to go
forward here he's got to play knight g5 and
he just does it wow logic logic logic logic
such logical moves he just does it he just
it's not i couldn't even finish my sentence
wow doubles in trouble he's got what he's got to
go bishop e2 probably or f i mean f4 yeah if he
plays f4 there's a draw for black i think we'll
see um we'll see if logic does it or not i'm not
the problem is logic logical is is a word that
i use a lot to explain certain moves or ideas so
it's like i'm not trying to make the pun it's just
normally what i would say and so it's like oh yeah
it's like i really oh my gosh it's going to
happen please don't play rook d7 or rook d3
uh-huh oh no oh but he wants through audrey
is trying to put the rook behind the pawn he's
trying to show a deep concept and double had
to go king g2 king f2 because now he's cut off
right and now the funny thing is now rook d7 is a
great move the move that tubbo desperately wanted
is actually a great movie yes to bring the rook
back otherwise rook d8 rook d1 it's game over
this is crazy but both players are i mean
tubbo is now getting a little bit low on time
as well he's admit he's a buck 20 and counting
he plays it very nice move by tabo that is a
high-class move rook takes pawn for free rook d8
rook d1 and that was that was just was that just
game over that was game over yeah yeah exactly
i mean i think there's i still think logic has
good chances to draw this game but it's there's no
guarantee now no guarantee at all i think this is
going to king vs king i think you're right but
that's what i was talking about now you check
rook takes pawn is a draw okay
uh he's got to go all the way back
only move rookie only move yeah okay
i told you no wow oh my gosh
oh oh logic didn't react in
the way like it was a mouse like
though either everyone stay calm
it's still not over i don't think oh wow this is
oh my gosh but this tub will know
how to check me here is the question
okay so if i go there
you can go there there there okay
king h3 is the only try right
yes change three and then you hope
for rook g5 to create the wrong ladder
yes but king g2 is all right so king
h3 oh my gosh he's bringing his king
this is fine i mean i don't
love it but it's still fine
oh my gosh tubbo tabo tabo tubbo
use the queen use the queen boss man
your king can't check the other king just use
the other two pieces there there it is there
it is there it is come on come on okay
okay not quite okay oh my god oh my god
no no no oh
no
i i don't even i don't even damn it
logic i want to start with you you were looking
locked in throughout that match how were
your nerves first of all throughout uh how was
it to play such a kind of high intensity match
and how are you feeling with the victory uh
i feel good um yeah tebow plays really really
dope that was super fun i was extremely nervous
uh i'm on my beth harmon i'm hungover because
last night was valentine's day and i had a bomb
time with my wife and uh so yeah man i feel great
it's the first time i've ever competed in my life
i don't know if y'all noticed i grew up broke
okay so i couldn't afford like a basketball
jersey to play on the team or nothing so
this is like my first time ever competing in
anything in my life and i'm having a blast
uh i guess openings wise taboo my question for
you is that very first game you seemed very eager
to trade away like you weren't even phased when
the when the queen drop happened like from you i
i don't okay so my i don't really know how to
describe what happened there i was just kind of
like well i could take it and then while i was
still thinking about it i'd already taken it so
and there wasn't much thought i'll be honest
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't some crazy mind
games it was like hmm i could take this oh oh
i've taken it ah gentlemen uh it was a pleasure
to have you on thank you for a fantastic match
we were we were blown away honestly you guys
continued the streak of fantastic games here and
we look forward to your next matchups thank you
you